greetings of peace to everybody all
around the globe you're tuning in to the
dean show and we got a young brother who
just graduated from loyola
university
and he got up there and he gave his
speech
and he talked about
some beautiful
advice about wasting time not wasting
time doing good and this is a muslim and
you see the media usually betray muslims
it's fanatics as soon as they start
practicing islam you got to work there
under the radar but this young brother
is practicing his deen he's praying but
before that he was an atheist
that's right he was an atheist so
we get some emails and sometimes where
you got some muslims they come from a
muslim background and you know we know
that this is something illogical you
know to not believe in the creator how
can you deny the sun it's right up there
but the maker who made the sun you're
denying him come on now and he was one
of those atheists so for the atheist the
skeptic you know people personally just
doesn't believe but he's tuned into the
dean show you're gonna want to sit tight
through this episode
so you can learn and benefit from his
experiences we'll be right back
this is
[Music]
[Music]
this is the
[Music]
you know what man i'm really excited you
know because you know i opened the show
and i talked about someone who was an
atheist
right and now you're one who has
consciously
made
the
decision that you know what islam is the
truth based on proof
and many people they go through the
rituals they're praying they're fasting
but you know what or not even that you
know they're going through it but they
don't know why they're doing it you know
now are you doing it with full
conviction that this way of life is from
the creator yeah of course but after
having gone through that journey over
the past four years
well how did you end up going through
that journey because your parents are
actually muslim right were they praying
were they were they um implementing
islam
yeah they tried their best to do so yeah
so let's let's go back in history we
want people to benefit from your story
because there's a lot of people in the
similar in this similar situation that
you are in so hopefully they can hear
your experience benefit from them and
then you know make a conscious decision
that you know what this this uh way that
i'm upon us doesn't make sense right but
what he's doing does make sense so let's
begin from the beginning how did it
start well i started back in high school
where
me and my friend one of my best friends
actually we started having doubts about
the religion because we were never
actually taught what the religion says
it was just like pray fast go to the
mosque whenever you can and that was
about the extent of our religious
knowledge
and then towards our senior year of high
school bill maher came out with a movie
called religious
and we both watched that and we both
became atheists after that point so when
i started college i was already atheist
but i want to
qualify that when i say atheists it
wasn't like
it was some logical reasoning that i
went through to come to that point of
being an atheist it was more like i was
never taught a religion so i was just
atheist to the idea of a god
so when you think about richard dawkins
he describes how he feels about fairies
and unicorns he says that i am atheist
to the idea of a unicorn so i'm a
unicornist i am an atheist to the idea
of a fairy someone a fairyist in the
same way he was an atheist to the idea
of a god and that's kind of how i was i
had no reason to believe i had no reason
to really think about it no one ever
talked about it with me none of my
friends ever talked about religion
the extent of my religious knowledge was
that
we can't eat to bihami
and that's pretty common in most
decisions
that was like as much as you know you
can't eat halal meat
that was it that was it all i knew was
that there was allah there was a man
named muhammad and he had a friend named
abu bakker yeah i had no idea what
hadees was i never heard there was
hadees in my life i never heard of what
a sahaba was yeah i never heard there's
something called nabi or rasool i never
even knew the quran was actually the
word of allah
all this time i thought the quran was a
word of just a bunch of arab men in
saudi arabia yeah that's all i knew like
literally
so now you see this movie which the
movie is really bashing christianity
it's showing the inconsistencies in
christianity that's what the movie is
really about yeah
so it's showing you know some of the
absurdities you know that are in the
bible you know and we're never trying to
disparage against anyone and we we take
strong exception when someone disparages
against god any of the prophets jesus
being one of them because we love jesus
and moses and abraham the last and final
messenger muhammad peace be upon him but
you'll see certain things in the bible
that we can't attribute to god or any of
the prophets that's clear there are
contradictions he exposes but bill maher
is his name right he exposes those
things but now that you investigated did
you obviously now you didn't know but
now have did you thoroughly investigate
islam the quran yeah i did eventually
but in the beginning i thought that well
if christianity is messed up then islam
must be messed up i just don't know i
don't care i don't think about it i have
no reason to think about it that's kind
of how i was i was just agnostic or
atheist to the idea of any religion in
general is did some pressure peer
pressure come from that because most
people they you know they want to follow
their desires they want to like because
it's a responsibility now if you believe
in the creator you have to believe that
like look he's the most wise he didn't
just create us and leave us without a
purpose so you didn't want to just think
about all that you put that all to the
side it wasn't like i had any real
desire no i wasn't ever partying never
had a girlfriend never smoked weed never
drank it was just that i just didn't
know i was very ignorant
and no one ever really encouraged me to
learn so i just didn't care to learn
so i thought well this is just all made
up it's all baloney yeah so i don't i
just don't want to know about it i don't
care about it no one talks about it none
of my friends ever talk about it we
never pray together
what what what i mean you're fairly
young so what do
you know the the people who are in your
age bracket uh younger older what was
usually the conversations like
just sports school like when i was in
high school i was in a lot of ap courses
and sports so we talked about that we
talked about working out
we talked about what supplements to take
a lot of my friends that girlfriends
will talk about that come on girlfriends
got to be on the top of the list now
women well for me honestly i just always
found women kind of annoying so
i never liked any of them huh
well but now someone thinks man this
guy's you know where he's going the
opposite the other way is that i know
that's what i mean like my story is kind
of different than most people it's not
like i was addicted to drugs or women
that caused me to yeah despair but
you're planning to get married soon
right did you get married yet no not yet
but are you planning to get married yeah
inshallah i would like to about okay may
allah find you the creator finds you
help you fight when you have a good
righteous woman masha allah so tell us
now what what okay the conversation
sports women and you know did anyone
ever bring up like purpose of life oh no
never never why do you think that is we
never knew about it yeah so we didn't
talk about it okay you go to school and
there's a purpose right right uh
obviously you know you have a curriculum
you got to go to class but what about
like our existence no one even bothered
to think you know i didn't i mean it's
not like you know i grew up people were
talking about it now that i look back
it's a blessing that you you're living
the purpose of life but before it's just
like you're thinking how could i have
not thought about that it never came up
in conversation i didn't know there's
something called a day of judgment i
don't even know that that's like the
basic tenant of our religion we die then
we go back and get judged i didn't know
that was even existing does that make
more sense now yeah think about it right
because people are dying every day it's
like a conveyor bed some people come
into this life and then leave this life
and then where do you go
we never thought about it we never
thought about it are you happy now that
you that you've thought about it you
know you're preparing for it
yeah okay so continue on okay you're in
school
you mentioned i mean how did you for for
someone young in college people go to
college okay it's like the creator
protected you from that but we know it's
a reality that people go to college for
the experience man for the parties you
know the frat parties that what they're
called frat parties yeah frats and you
had like 17 floors how many floors women
in the dorm i lived in there's 19 floors
in total called merch hall and i
mentioned that in my speech actually
yeah and there's only four floors of
boys
and the rest is all women that's like
for some men a heaven said they're like
i'm going to that school right some some
guys would just go to school for that
actually it's funny you mentioned that
because one of my friends before coming
to college yeah he texted me where
should i live in terms of dorms yeah and
i said look man i recommend you stay
away from merch hall but he's like no i
kind of like mercel i'm gonna go there
yeah he's a muslim guy too yeah even
though i told him not to go there and
that's where he applied yeah so how did
you okay there's a lot of
mixing between the men and women yeah
right yeah so obviously from there i
mean you put men and women together
there's going to be some trouble that
happens huh people are dating hooking up
you know is that happening yeah it
happened daylight right it's just like
just like chewing gum huh yeah i would
wake up in the morning there'll be some
girl passed out on my dorm floor
or something they'll be like vomit all
over the bathrooms vomit i mean so how
did you not uh get caught up into all of
that i honestly i don't even know
allah's mercy he kept me away from all
those sins yeah
i mean you can't tell just this is off
the subject but i know any woman that
just you know wakes up like that or man
you know it's kind of cool in our
society i mean i've been there done that
where you see that and it's kind of cool
that the man he's slept with all these
women right he's like
but has it become today how about the
woman now i mean is she can she like
what do you have you seen from your
experiences can a woman like go home you
know to mom and dad's house and she's
got a resume that she's like been with
30 guys from the dorm they just like you
know she's been on maury povich you are
the father
[Applause]
she's been on maury povich maybe can't
figure out who the baby's daddy is i
think that's a hypocrisy of the culture
where if a man does it it's kind of cool
yeah if a woman does it she's looked
very down upon mm-hmm
so i mean to live the organic way of
like that's pleasing to the creator
because i mean jesus wouldn't obviously
promote fornication and even if you're a
christian or a jew when a woman in
advance well you know a person of god
consciousness you got to realize that's
wrong you don't you don't have
you you're conscious in the beginning
saying because i had a little sister and
if i never wanted someone to do anything
to her i don't want to do something to
someone else's yeah if there ain't no
ring you ain't getting the thing that's
what you need to tell him
yeah women are more precious than you
know just uh uh uh we're trying to give
some good advice to our sisters and
humanity to beware the dogs right so
we'll be talking about more of this your
story here on the dean show don't go
anywhere we'll be right back it's like
when did you think that you had no
purpose
are you worthless
the value comes from purpose
your purpose in life is to worship the
creator not worship your desires and
self not worship social pressure the
celebrity culture but worship the thing
that's much higher and transcendent
above and beyond by worshiping god and
seeking his pleasure you get pleased so
you have double pleasure
back here on the dean show we're getting
your perspective i just want to go off
on this real quick because we want to
help save our sisters and humanity you
know because um i think it's very
important for her to get a guy's
perspective they did also like this is
not muslims doing this but they did on
college campuses asking can men and
women be friends yeah you see that yeah
i see that i mean what are our men's
minds i mean you're a unique situation
but what do most men want to want to do
with women
well i think it's kind of obvious but
they just want to get their way isn't it
fulfill their desire basically basically
yeah i mean you're we just want to
witness that from someone who just came
from graduated and was on the dorms you
were on the scene oh yeah what are your
thoughts on that yeah like all my
friends just talk about that every day
was like i wonder if i could get with
this girl they had something called a
gentleman's challenge where like a bunch
of guys on my floor were trying to sleep
with one particular girl and it was
called a gentleman's challenge there's
nothing gentlemen about it but
a gentleman so they describe it so that
there's guys who are betting a
gentleman's challenge if they can get
with a specific specific woman yeah that
was a gentleman's challenge freshman
year that's oppression of the woman
right there i mean and it's sad that the
woman's gotten caught up into this whole
you know game and she ends up getting
used and abused you know turn like a
door handle with so many guys and then
what you got you just tainted your soul
yeah i've seen this so many times yeah
so many times so many times so what's
what suggestion would you have for the
women
i would just say that just know if a
guy's a jerk it's kind of easy to tell
just from the stuff he talks about
and most guys in the age of 18 to 22 are
not thinking with their brains yeah they
have no intention of getting married at
that age
no intention no intention you know
unless they're really god-fearing you
know they want you to meet their parents
the parents are involved but this is
like old-fashioned nowadays but it's the
truth well that's that's a honest
reality yeah most guys are not thinking
about that they're not and women think
by giving the man sex that they'll get
him to fall in love but they're just
fooling themselves yeah that's as seen
as some even muslim women it happens
yeah
so so it's not something unique to the
american non-muslim culture anymore no
no no and if again if you're a christian
a jew a muslim you know islam is about
preserving the family
you know preserving the society by
preserving the family you preserve
society and you got a healthy
environment you know instead of all
these abandoned children stds broken
homes broken societies and women just
and men with just broken minds and
broken hearts that's a fact
is it fiction it's a fact it's a fact so
let's go back to your experience now you
know you're an atheist
what happened
to have you overcome that you know and
to come
to where you're at today now a muslim
one who is submitted to the will of god
the creator of the heavens and earth
talk to us well what happened was that
my freshman year when i was in the dorms
one of my friends named jamal he told me
that we're going to have ramadan prayer
started with prayers for those 30 nights
on campus
and then i said okay fine i'll come but
then i didn't go to any of them i was on
campus i could have easily walked in
five minutes and gone through the
prayers but i decided not to
and then i kind of felt bad for whatever
reason i just kind of felt bad that i
didn't go
and then i saw these posters up
everywhere that there would be an msa
event for an e dinner just to celebrate
the end of ramadan
and so i went to that and i know anybody
there and so i'm sitting there alone
there's hundreds of people men and women
faculty even non-muslim faculty who come
just to support the
and then this brother ali hazuma i
remember him very clearly he starts
reciting the quran
and
honestly that was like the most
beautiful thing
i had ever heard in my life
because when i when i was growing up i
used to write rap music and hip-hop
lyrics and record them myself like make
my own cds i never published them like
for a reason you wanted to be a rapper
oh yeah i used to write songs myself
yeah yeah you were like trying to do
this stuff yeah i used to record myself
because you got to do the hands you know
like yo get that uh-uh jab right yeah
stock for the luck yeah but i used to do
that stuff yeah recording you see how
foolish that is now yeah i can't believe
i was in there well your hands like or
your your your jeans were down to your
calves
kind of like that yeah you could see
myself
okay
see so i went to and this guy started
reciting and it was just the most
beautiful thing i'd ever heard
and then what i do is i go back to my
dorm room and because we live in the age
of technology i go on youtube and just
type in quran yeah and i spent the next
three weeks about six seven eight hours
a day just listening to people reciting
the quran
and then one day i actually come across
a deen show episode from several years
ago where you had dr subheal ahmad on it
it was something like
proof or evidence the quran is the word
of god or something like that and i
clicked on it and then i'm watching it
and i thought oh that's why i sound so
nice it's allah's words i didn't even
know that yeah even non-muslims know
that but i just didn't know that fact
that's something that pretty much
anybody knows
that muslims believe quran is a word of
allah or god i didn't even know that but
i was listening to this book for three
four weeks six seven eight hours a day
and had no idea until i watched a deen
show
masha'allah
tell us you know you're a medical
student now first year medical school
and to become a doctor you have to fuel
your brain with knowledge right right i
mean do you see now that you have you
have to put some time into learning this
way of life you know because many people
will even memorize the verbatim word of
god the quran but if you don't
internalize it i mean you do it for the
bark of the blessings but if you don't
know the meaning there's no benefit
behind how important is it to learn this
deen this way of life i think it's
probably more important to understand
even a few pages of the quran then just
to memorize it because i know many kids
personally who memorized it and ended up
forgetting it because they go into the
party scene i've seen that many times
also
but i've also seen many kids who have
maybe like the last 10 surahs memorized
or last 10 chapters
and they're the most amazing muslims i
know
because they really try to focus on what
they know they try to implement into
their lives they go over the mustard
regularly they try to read about what
they're learning they watch lectures
they attend lectures et cetera
so i think it's more important to
understand even a little bit
uh you you how do you feel because uh
you have a lot of
you know people
who malign islam
we know that islam is a way of life that
is
from the creator it's not organized by
human beings it's organized by the one
who created creation and anyone who
takes a sincere humble look at it reads
the quran studies the life of the
prophet muhammad peace be upon him who
was a brother to jesus moses abraham you
know call people to worship the creator
not his creation they will see that this
is not a man-made religion like you came
to find out right
so
when you see people
maligning it and trying to make it look
like it's some fanatic barbaric religion
and now you're someone who's you know
graduated from from university going to
be a medical doctor god willing you know
who's a productive citizen what do you
have to say to those people
i would just say that don't make the
mistake that i made if you have a
question about islam don't take it from
somebody who either left the religion or
someone who's not even following their
religion because that's what i did i had
a question i went to bill maher richard
dawkins sam harris all these famous
atheists and agnostics
but then i didn't really think like why
don't i go and talk to someone who's
actually following their religion
and when i started doing that i realized
what the religion is really all about so
if you have a question
talk to someone who is following their
religion not from someone else
okay did you get a chance to look at
myself
speaking of myself i opened up a world
religions book i wanted to make sure
that this is way of life because i think
anyone who's come to islam we have a lot
of
bible scholar christian scholars you
know hindus people from from around the
world that they've they really took an
analytical scientific approach they
investigated islam because islam is not
calling you to blind belief allah is
telling us in the khan to think
to ponder where did this book you know
effort
[Music]
had it been from other than the creator
you would find much contradiction in it
there's no contradiction the creator is
challenging you right so
why so i looked at christianity i looked
at hindu and all the other world
religions and it just doesn't make sense
you don't have to go too far you know
into it but the more you get into islam
the more you're convinced from your
experience i mean you know
what are some of the things that you
know your friends people ask you you
know why didn't you look at christianity
why didn't you say jesus is your lord
and savior you know why don't you go
into that
after christian hinduism what what would
you say well actually when i was in
college my majors were history and
religious studies so i spent the last
year and a half years studying different
religions so it's not like anyone can
tell me that i didn't look into other
religions after my conversion i did i
studied hinduism hinduism i started
judaism buddhism
i mean i was an atheist before agnostic
kind of related but i studied everything
but
at the end islam still made the most
sense it made the most sense yeah do you
feel that anyone
that would give it the time of day right
didn't just you know you think it's a a
a cop-out when someone just okay they
come from a way of life and again we're
not trying to disparage on anybody we're
just trying to have people think they
say okay this trinity doesn't make sense
for instance or worshiping like you know
uh uh three the sun or the moon or three
thousand gods you know in some religions
and they just say you know what this is
all man-made they say oh i don't believe
in any organized religion but they don't
give islam a shot are they are they are
they uh selling themselves off short
that's exactly what i did yeah i was
religious he spent the most of the movie
making fun of the idea of christianity
and i interpret that as well if
christianity doesn't make sense nothing
makes sense and that's kind of mistake i
made i didn't really bother
investigating islam yeah that you don't
want to do that's like peyton
you know people with the same brush
right yeah that's exactly what i did
yeah okay let's take a break we'll be
right back with more here with our
brother mansoor
on the dean show and it's simple to
understand i wouldn't know what the sky
looked like what the trees looked like i
would have never seen the faces of my
beautiful children
if i didn't have the ability to see
how blessed we are by allah and
obedience is born out of gratitude so
thank him call upon him establish a
relationship with him forget about the
past take it out of being a ritual
and make it a spiritual experience islam
is not something dubious
unclear hazy
it's really straightforward he said it
changed his life
he said he saw every single episode that
you had ever recorded
[Music]
back here on the dean's show former
atheist graduate from
loyola university do you feel that the
the campuses that's a lot of the
professors that they push atheism on the
students
i think some of the philosophy
professors do but in my experience the
jesuit professors we're actually the
most open-minded nicest kindest people
i've ever met for someone doesn't know
what that is what is that a jesuit is
like a priest in the catholic order yeah
the catholic church
and they've always encouraged you know
religious freedom and tolerance and
interfaith i mean they even let me
recycle on at graduation they let us do
our own events invite our own speakers
they gave us our own masjid with our own
wadu center yeah so that's really nice
of him yeah really nice yeah yeah so
uh so tell us uh
obviously you're you're praying five
times a day yeah you're getting ready
for ramadan yeah
uh do you find it challenging
in a way that you know many people
they're neglecting salah because you
know the dunya you know the the worldly
life is taking over but you're studying
you're making time for salat
is this improving your life yeah i think
it's better i need that personal time to
have my fudge your time i shine the
masjid i think it's better for me in the
times where i just neglect all that and
focus on studying yeah what advice do
you give for some people older young you
know male or female who they're just
like i'm just so busy you know uh i
don't have time to pray what do you tell
them i think it's honestly just an
excuse
i i really believe
people who want to pray they'll figure
out a way to pray people who don't want
to pray don't make any excuse not to
pray yeah it's just that simple you'll
take time to uh call
your
beloved on the phone ten times a day
right and those conversations will last
more than five minutes or maybe a
cigarette break right haram break
but to thank the creator
you don't have a few minutes yeah like i
said i think it's all excuses excuse huh
we really want to motivate people to
connect with their creator you did
something also we we are
we are it's an obligation on every
muslim one submitted to the will of god
to share because we care the purpose of
life with the world
and and you took that opportunity you
know that's that's what got our
attention here at the dean show there's
a video out there of you at your
graduation yeah and you're actually
reciting you know part of the quran well
asir you know indeed you know all
mankind is in a state of law except
those who believe right
and follow that belief up with good
deeds good actions
talk to us about this
you mean like how i got selected yeah
how how what made you want to uh at your
at your graduation now in a speech
to to recite the quran well actually i
didn't want to even give the speech to
be honest with you i just wanted to
recite so i emailed the president father
michael garanzini
and he liked the idea but because of his
cabinet they've decided it's best that i
don't because then the hindu kids want
to do something and the jewish kids want
to do something so they decide it was
best that we don't do that
so i just applied to give the graduation
speech and there's about 30 kids who
applied and i got selected from all
those 30 kids and the dean called me and
told me that i've been selected and then
at the last day the morning of the
speech i asked him like hey man can i
recycle on yeah he's like yeah sure it's
your day do whatever you want
that was his response exactly that's
what he said it's your day do whatever
you want masha'allah so what happened
you didn't just recite the quran because
it's been preserved we have it in its
original tamper-free tamper-proof it's
for everyone wants to take take take a
look but we have it now and you gave the
meaning behind it you translated it
right yeah
what what was this translation talk to
us about it what was the the the the the
message behind what you said the basic
message was just that we shouldn't waste
our time and just to be sincere in
everything that we do and to take
advantage of every opportunity that we
have to do good and i use the example
that even the jesuits they do a lot of
they try to do their best for the world
they go everywhere they try to
feed the poor
i mean like in their in whatever
understanding they have they're trying
to do the best that they can and that's
something that i think every human
should try to do
whatever understanding that we have our
religions we try to promote those the
main thing that we try to have people
reflect on to have that built on a
foundation of pure monotheism that we do
with the sincere intention to please the
one god pure monotheism and that's what
jesus taught moses abraham and that's
islam submission to the will of god and
you alhamdulillah you know you you you
were you were giving this advice
so for the people that are stuck all day
you know playing uh xbox grand theft
auto you know watching jersey shores you
know just wasting time does this go back
with the advice you were given
yeah like most of my friends who i
started school with their pre-med they
don't make it because they're every day
they're staying up late two three in the
morning watching tv playing video games
on facebook or something they wake up at
11 12 1 o'clock the next day they missed
class
until this day nerd them in medical
school but the kids went to sleep on
time they woke up on time they're also
medical school with me now yeah so
before we cut out you know that's why we
wanted to to encourage people that a you
can be one who is practicing the way of
life from the creator and you can end up
being a doctor graduating from school
not ending up some fanatic right yeah of
course not so obviously you can be
someone who's well balanced you can be
the best in this life because that's
what the creator wants for us to be the
best but don't neglect your
responsibility towards your creator and
preparing for what comes next the day of
judgment what are your thoughts on that
yeah like you said it's all about
balance it's nothing
complicated about being successful
it's just about being able to like so i
have a balanced schedule where i have
time for the quran time for school spend
time my family i call my mom and dad
every day i just have everything in
order now
for the person that's also an atheist
agnostic
and they're kind of relating to your
story what advice would you give for
them i would just say that if you have a
question about islam talk to a muslim
talk to several muslims i encourage you
go to the mosque just try it out no
one's gonna throw you out and they
shouldn't at least
i mean that's what i used to do with all
my friends who are formerly non-muslims
i would just say yes pray with me who
cares yeah just come to the masjid with
me and over the years several of them
did end up becoming muslim
and that was only because i kept an open
arm to them and try to read books on
islam not
mistake that i made which is go to an
atheist or an agnostic or someone who
apostated from their religion and asked
that individual questions it's best to
ask a source
from people who have knowledge that'll
be my number one advice and you see
people most people let's say because you
mentioned left is because they weren't
implementing it they didn't understand
it right and they came and thought it
was something like some hocus pocus and
you can just say i believe and you're
gonna be you know saved no requires work
and you're starting to do the work and
you're starting to see the benefits yeah
alhamdulillah may allah reward you the
creator of the heavens and earth
and maybe when you graduate from medical
school we'll get you to give some some
advice here how we can stay in better
health huh yeah
we'll see you again thank you alex and
thank you for tuning in to the dean show
take a look at this quran it's from the
creator of the heavens and the earth
take a look at it sincerely and you look
around you you see the sun and the stars
you see the galaxies it didn't just
happen by chance that doesn't make sense
that doesn't make sense for any
pondering
person who really reflects and thinks
you look at the heavens and the earth
and all the different
beautiful things of creation
and there's no way that you can just
just just come to that conclusion all of
that happened by chance so really think
about it and within yourself ask do like
one of our guests has shared with him
with us his story he did the skeptics
prayer he said you know if there is a
god if you're out there guide me even
start with that even start with that
because
this way of life is only promoting
goodness
or organic way of living and that's what
we're all shooting for right whole foods
isn't it we all want organic well islam
is an organic way of life calling you to
everything pure
wholesome goodness and at the end what
do you got if you lived a good life then
you got paradise
but if you're an atheist and you just
die and then it's the hellfire is true
which is is and paradise is true which
it is but you didn't work for it then
what do you got you only have yourself
to blame and the signs are clear one of
them is that you're turning in here to
the dean's show and continue to tune in
every week and call us 1-800-662 to
start a healthy dialogue we'll see you
next time until then peace be with you